Trascrizione: Beatrice Vecchiato
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Non ho mai pensato veramente
che fare l'illustratore
fosse un lavoro possibile.
Sinceramente pensavo
che per pagare le bollette,
pagare l'affitto,
per chiunque avesse un attitudine
al disegno o all'illustrazione,
alla fine, sarebbe stato meglio
fare un qualcosa di più concreto
come lavorare come
grafico o pubblicitario,
ecco perché all'inizio della mia carriera
ho lavorato come
art director in pubblicità.
Poi un'altra convinzione che avevo
era quella che, no matter what,
alla fine sarei finito a vivere
e lavorare a New York,
la città dei miei sogni.
Ecco che per coronare la seconda parte
decido nel 2012 con la mia ragazza
di partire per New York
per la nostra prima volta lì.
La classica vacanza,
dieci giorni in relax.
Poi io, in maniera astuta,
avrei piazzato qualche colloquio,
qualche incontro per capire il mercato,
insomma se come art director
fossi stato a livello
del livello medio americano.
Quindi nell’ottobre del 2012
atterriamo, però già qualcosa non torna.
Il pilota, appena arrivati,
si scusa di un qualcosa,
dice una certa Sandy.
Ce ne freghiamo, non ho capito.
Andiamo in città, andiamo
a Manhattan e passeggiamo felici,
però ci accorgiamo
che fuori dai negozi sono dei cartelli
con scritto “Per colpa di Sandy
chiuderemo alle 3”,
“Per colpa di Sandy i mezzi pubblici
smetteranno di funzionare
verso le tre e mezza”.
Non capiamo cominciamo
a chiedere in giro
e scopriamo che sarebbe successo questo:
New York da lì a qualche ora
sarebbe stata invasa
da una tempesta-uragano
che ha spento metà New York,
da Times Square in giù,
bloccando la città
i mezzi pubblici non funzionavano,
un traffico incredibile perché ovviamente
tutti si mettevano in macchina
Dei nostri dieci giorni,
5-6 li abbiamo passati chiusi in albergo
dove ci avvertivano di non uscire
per non rischiare la vita,
i restanti quattro giorni a passeggiare
per una città fondamentalmente inutile
e ovviamente anche i miei colloqui
perché uffici chiusi,
nessuna possibilità di fare proprio
neanche una mezza chiacchiera.
Quindi, rientriamo in Italia
Questa cosa brucia un po',
continua a crescere e crescere.
Nel 2013 quindi, neanche tempo sei mesi,
decido che ci devo provare
con più convinzione.
Però devo andarci convinto,
devo andarci preparato.
Quindi, decido che devo contattare
tutti i grandi director
delle agenzie pubblicitarie
e nel caso non mi avessero risposto
mi sarei presentato di persona,
incontro a sorpresa: "Eccomi qua,
guardami ci sono".
Però non voglio nessun paracadute,
non voglio alibi, non voglio
motivi per mollare.
Quindi, do le dimissioni.
Non ho un lavoro sono disoccupato,
parto per New York.
Per attirare l'attenzione
dei direttori creativi
disegno la mia storia.
La mia storia illustrata, senza scrivere
la mail: "Ciao scusami sono...".
No, ti racconto la mia storia
come un libro per bambini.
Questi sono i clienti mostruosi, terribili
che mi chiedevano le cose più indicibili,
parlo del mio viaggio a New York,
che sono lì apposta per loro,
la mail si chiude con un 'Sì' o un 'No'.
Il direttore creativo poteva cliccare sì:
mi arrivava una mail precompilata
non doveva sbattersi.
Scriveva l'orario, scriveva il giorno
e mi fissava l'appuntamento.
Cliccava no: non doveva sbattersi
a scrivermi "Mi dispiace..."
arrivava già la mail:
"Davide, mi dispiace
non abbiamo voluto incontrarti".
Grazie a questa storia, i risultati
sono stati veramente straordinari:
ho ricevuto il cento per cento
di risultati negativi.
Allora, bisogna un attimo spiegare però:
il 70 per cento effettivamente
non ha risposto,
il 20 per cento ha cliccato no,
il 10 per cento mi ha
confermato il colloquio,
quindi c'è stato anche un motivo
di gaudio inizialmente
però poi, una volta presentati,
già si capiva che "No sponsorship",
nessuna possibilità. Quindi, proprio zero.
Ovviamente, la frustrazione aumenta
perché chi incontro,
tutti che hanno,
in una maniera o nell'altra,
realizzato il proprio sogno americano.
Quindi comincio a dire:
"Sei a New York, ce la puoi fare.
Tutti alla fine ottengono
una possibilità qui.
Quindi, mi gioco la carta
dell'incontro a sorpresa.
Mi presento alle agenzie e dico:
"Raga, io sono qua,
sono venuto apposta dall'Italia per voi,
voglio l'incontro col direttore creativo.
Mi dicono che senza un incontro preparato,
fissato, io non posso stare li.
Dimentico che dopo l'11 settembre
le policy di sicurezza
sono un po' cresciute,
quindi, io insisto, dico
che voglio rimanere lì
che voglio il mio colloquio e loro
mi fanno scortare da una guardia fuori.
Le cose non vanno tanto bene,
quindi rientro in Italia.
Allora dico: "Proviamo con Londra".
Provo con Londra; stesso mindset.
Conosco gente, vedo direttori creativi.
Qui va un po' meglio,
arrivo addirittura in finale
con un altro art director inglese
per il posto di art director
in una importante agenzia pubblicitaria.
Il direttore creativo però
se ne lava le mani e dice:
"Io non voglio scegliere,
siete entrambi a pari livello".
Quindi fa scegliere al copywriter,
il tuo futuro compagno
di squadra, diciamo,
e tra me e il ragazzo inglese
chi pensate abbia scelto?
Non ha scelto me. Così vi rispondo già.
Quindi, torno in Italia.
Sono disoccupato, mi conoscono
più o meno come art director
e quindi comincio a valutare l'idea
che la mia passione da illustratore
forse è da cominciare a rivalutare.
Proviamoci, vediamo com'è.
Quindi, mi apro due siti,
uno da art director e uno da illustratore.
Oltretutto, da illustratore,
per fare i passi giusti,
contatto alcuni illustratori italiani,
chiedendo dei pareri
sul mio stile, come lavoro,
se potrebbe funzionare come carriera.
C'è chi mi motiva,
mi da dei giusti consigli,
chi invece mi dice: "Senti,
come art director
stavi andando bene in Italia,
continua a fare l'art director.
lascia stare l'illustratore,
non è una carriera che fa per te".
Io mi intestardisco
e mi apro questi due siti,
pensando di raddoppiare
le possibilità di clienti
e invece, in realtà mi arrivano
delle mail che dicono:
"Guarda che c'è uno che hai tuoi
stessi lavori, però ha un altro nome.
Ma chi è quello che ha fatto i lavori?
Mi piace l'illustratore che è di là.
Me lo contatti?
Sto facendo confusione.
Quindi, chiudo il sito da art director
Provo a mettermi il cappello
da illustratore e dico:
"Raga, io sono un illustratore.
Non è andata bene a New York
le ultime due volte.
Nel 2015 la frustrazione aumenta
e dico: "Senti sai che c'è?
Io ci torno a New York.
Mi deve la mia possibilità.
Io voglio il sogno americano
e mi deve la mia possibilità.
Riparto da illustratore.
Mindset ancora diverso,
la città la conosco,
l'ho già girata, non mi interessa.
So che andrò lì e contatterò
tutti i giornali, le riviste,
le agenzie di pubblicità tutti i giorni.
Non mi interessa.
Non voglio andare in giro per la città.
Appena atterro, contatto un'amica.
Questa mi offre ospitalità
nel suo ufficio.
Lei fa l'agente di fotografi,
quindi c'è tutto lo spazio
per poterti mettere a cercare.
Cerco, mando mail
per i successivi sette giorni,
mando mail otto ore al giorno
e ricevo totale zero risposte
o al massimo le risposte che ricevo
sono risposte automatiche:
"Ciao sono fuori per lavoro,
non posso rispondere".
Però, a un certo punto succede una cosa,
mi arriva una mail inaspettata:
mi contatta il Washington Post
con una proposta:
"Vogliamo metterti in copertina
con una tua illustrazione su un tema".
"Ditemi".
Washington Capitals,
la nostra squadra di hockey,
andrà molto probabilmente in finale
e noi vogliamo celebrare l'approdo finale
con una tua illustrazione".
Ok, va bene, facciamola subito!
"No, c'è un però".
"Come c'è un però?"
"Si, è stasera che giochiamo
la gara decisiva:
se vinciamo e andiamo in finale,
illustrazione tua sparata
gigante sul magazine,
se non vinciamo, niente.
Ah, puoi avvantaggiarti se vuoi, così
i tempi di consegna saranno più veloci.
Però, sappi che se perdiamo,
non ti verrà rimborsato nulla.
Decidi tu cosa fare: puoi aspettare
anche della fine della partita".
Ragazzi, mi contatta il Washington Post,
non comincio?
E inizio.
Mando degli schizzi
loro mi approvano la prima,
quella centrale: sopra un giocatore
simbolo dei Washington Capitals,
sotto, giocatore di Tampa Bay
che sarebbe la squadra
che avrebbero incontrato in finale.
Comincio, la realizzo, la mando.
Un'amica mi dice: "Senti ma,
vuoi venire a vedere la partita?
Perché guarda caso
giocano contro New York!
Andiamo a vedere la partita.
Però questa mia amica
mi porta a vederla nel covo dei Rangers.
Per spiegarvela meglio,
è come se io da milanista andassi
a vedere il derby Milan-Inter
nel covo di interisti sfegatati.
Io me ne sto zitto, guardo la partita,
la mia birretta.
Dopo tre minuti Washington
segna: uno a zero.
Siamo a cavallo, ormai è fatta.
Sta facendo anche la partita.
Secondo tempo New York pareggia
un'azione fortuita, veramente.
Lasciamo perdere.
Washington fa la partita.
Terzo tempo, non segna nessuno.
Si va ai supplementari.
Ai supplementari succede questo:
i blu sono New York.
E questi sono più o meno
800 dollari che vanno in fumo
con un'azione difesa male.
Ringraziamo Washington.
Ovviamente qui ho il crollo più totale.
La mia unica possibilità,
questo è un segno dall'alto,
lo leggo come segno dall'alto:
"Davide, lascia perdere,
fare l'illustratore non è il tuo.
Hai avuto la tua possibilità?
Han difeso male? Basta, cambia,
fai l'art director, riusciva bene.
Quindi, ovviamente,
arrivo in ufficio dove ero ospite
con un muso lunghissimo.
L'amica mi guarda e mi fa:
"Cos'è successo?"
Allora evito di rispondere con parolacce,
e spiego: "Abbiamo perso".
E mi fa: "Ma ascolta, perché non prendi
l'illustrazione che hai fatto,
la cambi con New York vincente
e la mandi ai magazine di New York?"
Si però raga, io ci ho provato
un sacco di volte,
cioè ancora? Ancora
per essere deluso un'altra volta?
Non ha risposto nessuno fino ad adesso,
probabilmente non è il mio.
Dovrò fare altro.
Però poi alla fine mi passa
questa mini depressione
e quindi cambio l'illustrazione
e realizzo questa.
Comincio a mandarla
ai vari magazine di New York
e il New York Times risponde.
Mi dice: "Davide,
complimenti per il lavoro.
Non ci serve, non la vogliamo, grazie.
Però se vuoi passa,
ci facciamo due chiacchiere
capiamo insomma come lavori.
Cavolo, non me lo dire due volte.
Prendo, chiudo la porta,
esco, vado in ufficio,
corro sotto il New York Times
e mando una mail casuale,
non pensavo di mandarla:
"Ciao ragazzi, casualmente sono qui sotto,
posso salire?
Secondo voi cosa mi hanno risposto?
No.
In realtà mi hanno risposto:
"No, vediamoci domani."
Erano in riunione, quindi il giorno dopo
facciamo la riunione,
però io non mi illudo.
Alla fine la delusione è stata
troppo recente
e quindi dico: "Vabbè,
non si sa come andrà."
Però son contento, ho ottenuto
il mio colloquio al New York Times.
Ad un certo punto, però,
dopo tre giorni mi arriva
effettivamente una richiesta da loro.
Impazzisco.
Mi dicono: "Davide, hai cinque ore
di tempo perché c'è una breaking news.
Hanno appena beccato Blatter
con le mani nella marmellata.
Blatter era l'ex presidente FIFA,
l'hanno beccato che distribuiva mazzette
insieme a tutto l'establishment FIFA.
Serve un'illustrazione.
Mi mandano l'articolo,
e io lì non capisco più niente.
Più o meno i ricordi
vanno in sequenza così
e più o meno alla stessa velocità:
chiama il New York Times, urlo,
dicono: "Perché urli?"
"Mi ha chiamato il New York Times".
Ok, chiamo un taxi, salgo in taxi
per correre a lavorare.
Chiamo la mia ragazza in Italia.
Le dico che ha chiamato il New York Times.
Lei urla. Metto giù il telefono.
Scendo dal taxi, pago il taxi,
do la mancia, troppa mancia!
Non importa.
Sto andando. Entro in casa,
accendo la luce, spengo la luce,
accendo...si brucia la lampadina.
Va beh, non importa, ne ho giusto una.
Allora, mi metto davanti al computer
e comincio a lavorare.
Leggo l'articolo, penso,
mando le proposte,
tutte incentrate su Blatter.
Mentre aspetto che mi diano una risposta
alle mie quattro proposte,
cambio la lampadina.
Arriva la risposta
Cannate tutte.
La mia unica possibilità: bruciata.
Con delle proposte,
a quanto pare non a livello.
Loro mi spiegano che erano
tutte troppo incentrate su Blatter
e che invece era una cosa
che doveva riguardare tutta la Fifa.
Grazie, c'hai provato.
Il tempo è troppo poco,
va bene così. C'hai provato.
Io faccio: "No ragazzi, vi prego,
datemi un'altra mezz'ora di tempo."
"Ma con mezz'ora di tempo
avresti tre ore di tempo
per realizzare l'illustrazione,
sei sicuro?"
"Dammi mezz'ora di tempo,
e ti do l'illustrazione."
Mi danno questa mezz'ora di tempo
comincio a pensare.
"Allora, FIFA, cosa fa la FIFA?
La FIFA organizza i mondiali,
organizza i mondiali,
la manifestazione più importante
quindi, hanno rotto la FIFA:
faccio una Coppa del Mondo rotta.
No, la Coppa del Mondo rotta no,
alla fine la Coppa del Mondo è solida
Coppa del Mondo, Mondo,
il mondo è tondo...
è tipo una lampadi...
lampadina bruciata!
Faccio che hanno sgamato
il mondo che hanno rovinato
e quindi facciamo e hanno cambiato
il mondo alla Coppa del Mondo.
Mando questo schizzo.
Appunto, due mani...
Lo vedono, me lo approvano subito.
Vai, realizza l'illustrazione.
Io, in tre ore di tempo,
chiudo l'illustrazione.
Che diventa così.
Ovviamente, l'art director
dall'altra parte felicissimo.
Io sono lì che già mi sto pregustando
la mia entrata in edicola, tipo:
"Mi dia la copia del New York Times"
per leggere il mio nomino sotto,
ma arriva una mail.
Cosa c'è adesso?
L'editor l'ha vista
e ha detto: "Bellissima,
però è perfetta per quando cambieranno
tutto il management della FIFA.
E ci saranno le effettive
dimissioni di Blatter."
"Ok ma, e quindi questo quando succederà?"
"Eh no, tra un anno".
Come tra un anno.
Quindi effettivamente poi,
sarò sincero, è uscita
un anno dopo, fatta in tre ore
per la mattina successiva,
però è uscita, un anno dopo.
Però, diciamo che questa illustrazione
ha rotto degli argini
e da lì ho continuato a lavorare per loro
per altri brand sportivi,
dell'editoria, per pubblicità,
per squadre sportive anche.
Qui sono alcuni dei progetti
ai quali ho lavorato recentemente.
Però, in conclusione,
se sono qui a parlarvi,
è perché sono un illustratore
adesso al 100 per centro,
ma probabilmente, anzi quasi sicuramente,
se non mi fosse andata di sfiga
per tutto questo tempo,
ora non sarei qui a parlarvi.
Quindi, in attesa
della mia prossima sfortuna
vi ringrazio per avermi ascoltato.
[Applauso]